[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم ما في برنامج اسبوع في
العالم برنامج نستعرض فيها ابرز احداث
الاسبوع ما عدد من الزملاء ولا اصدقاء
يمكنكم بالطبع ان تتفاعلوا مع مايقوله
ضيوف البرنامج على صفحتنا على فيسبوك
فيسبوك
او على صفحه البرنامج
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه والتي لم
تعطي نتائج الاغلبيه الساحقه للحزب
الجمهوري مثل ما توقعت عمليات استطلاع
الراي ننهي بالاستراتيجيه العسكريه
الجديده التي يعدها الرئيس
القاره السمراء تحديدا وانا سعيد طبعا
بمشاركه زميلتي في منطقه
الدوليه سعيد ايضا بان تكون معي ميناء
القاهره وطبعا كريستي لم تضع الاسماء اصلا
همم اسماء الضيوف غير بقى غير
وجوده وكريستين
سعد صابر هناك في الاستديو طبعا طبعا طبعا
وبعدين
حنان البدري من القاهره عارف اسمها فقدت
حتى المره المقبله نكتب كل شيء ومن واشنطن
هدايا يعقوب وهو كاتب وصحفي اهلا وسهلا
بكم طيب نبدا مع ضيفتي من القاهره
واسالك كنا ننتظر قمه لعبد الفتاح السيسي
فسمعنا قمه علي عبد الفتاح علي عبد الفتاح
عبد الفتاح يعني خيبت قضيه علي عبد الفتاح
على هذه القمه
بان مساله حقوق الانسان كان مقرر لها ان
تكون على راس الموضوعات المهمه التي
ستناقش ذلك من قبل الجمعيات والمنظمات
الحقوقيه ربما اكثر منها من قبل الدول
التي سترك نقطه مهمه جدا لازم نقولها هنا
بان مشاركه همم
كان فيها تردد وحسن الامر بعد ما تنفس
الصدا همم قليلا نتيجه النتائج المبدئيه
للانتخابات الامريكيه او النصفيه وربما
معظم النتائج ايضا همم هناك لابد وان
نتذكر هنا بان الشان المؤتمر في حد ذاتي
هو مهمه بالنسبه للحزب الديمقراطي للرئيس
الديمقراطي بالنسبه لرئيس المؤتمر اللي هو
اصلا همم احد زعمات الديمقراطيه وهو جون
كيري ولذا راينا نانسي فيلوزي تاتي ومعها
فريق او همم وافده من الحزب الديمقراطي في
مقابل همم وجود ملحوظ
للقائمين على المؤتمر وليس لم يكن لهم
يعني همم وجود اعلامي يذكر وهو الوفد الذي
يمثل الحزب الجمهوري وكما تعلم فان ترامب
نهى ده خلال فتره رئاسته كجمهوري مساله
همم المناخ وضروره التعاون الدولي همم
حل مشاكل الكره الارضيه من هذه الناحيه
لذا محاولات هذا الوفد جاءت ايضا همم يعني
كاعتذار خفيف او القول بانهم مقتنعون وان
ما تناقشه القمه مهمه بالنسبه للحزب
الجمهوري
ورايتم النتائج في امريكا والتي اعتقد
سناء عرج عليها لاحقها
ولكن الملف الخاص بي علاء عبد الفتاح ربما
كان البعض يتوقع عن الرئيس الامريكي
جيبايدن بمجرد قدومه سيتناول بشكل موسع
ملف حقوق الانسان وكان ملف حقوق الانسان
سيطغى على زياره الرئيس الامريكي ولكن
تفاجا كثيرون انه ركز بشكل اكبر كما ذكرت
همم سيد حنانا وركز على الشقه المتعلق
بالمناخ كون هذا الملف هو الملف الاهم
بالنسبه توليه للرئاسه لكن همم موضوع على
عبد الفتاح تحديدا اخذ جانبا هو بسبب
التغطيه الاعلاميه الاسيه ما بعد زياره
شقيقه علاء عبد الفتاح لمقر انعقاد قمه
المناخ في شرم الشيخ وتجمع حولها كثيرون
من همم نشطاء المجتمع المدني المتخصصون في
حقوق مجال حقوق الانسان وبعض حتى ال- ال-
المنظمات التي شاركت في هذه القمه والتي
كان من المفترض ان تكون منظمات خاصه
بالمناخ وان تناقش مواضيع المناخ ربما
البعض منها ركزت على جانب حقوق الانسان
لدرجه انه في الاوساط المصريه هناك عريضه
يوقع عليها كثيرون لتذهب الى الامم
المتحده ل همم الحديث او لكي تسجل موقفا
من
مجموعه من المنظمات التي حضرت هذه القمه
على اعتبار انها منظمات خاصه بمجال المناخ
ولكنها همم تحدثت او ركزات واثارت مواضيع
اخرى وكانت سببا في دخول النشطه الى داخل
مقر القمه ل همم التظاهر او ل همم اثبات
موقف حتى انها مجموعه من النشطاه لاحظنا
انهم كانوا يرتدون همم يعني قمصان تحت
قمصانهم عليها هاشتاج على الحريه على عبد
الفتاح انا كل ذلك كان مرتبا اذا كانت
هناك همم ترتيبات من العائله ومن همم ربما
اشخاص كثر ممن يؤيدون هذه القضيه ولذلك
جاءت جاء هذا التركيز الكبير على علاء عبد
الفتاح خلال القمه لدرجه ان البعض قال هي
قمه علاء عبد الفتاح
بسيط اذا سمحت لي بتوضيح يعني بسيط هنا
وهو مهم للغايه ليس عاده كل ما يناقش في
الغرف المغلقه خلال الاجتماعات على مستوى
سياسي همم يتم همم الدفع بقى به لوسائل
الاعلام اريد هنا ان اوضح نقطه واحد همم
يعني مهمه جدا والنقطه دي بتلزمنا بان
عوده الى اخر لقاء دم بين الرئيس السيسي
وبين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وذلك في
جده اذا تذكرته على حد علمي بانه كانت
هناك بعض المطالبات الامريكيه همم بعضها
متعلق بحقوق الانسان بعدها متعلقه حتى
اسلوب التعاطي الحكومي المصري مع او
الاداء الاقتصادي المصري وضروره ان يكون
همم مدنيه بالضروره ال- همم مساله القرود
وكان هناك توافقات وطلبات معينه وعندما
لما تقوم القاهره بالتعاطي مع تلك الطلبات
على مدى زمنيه معينه همم راينا همم كيف تم
تخفيض القروض اللي كانت من المفترض ان
تمرر عبر اا ال- ال- البنك الدولي عبر
جهات اخرى بشكل سلس كما كان متوقعا ولده
همم وربما اقول بان خلال مكالمه تليفونيه
مع احد الاعضاء من الديمقراطيين الذين
كانوا متواجدين في همم تلك القمه بالامس
حتى قبل همم وصول بيض كانت هناك همم
تاكيدات بان همم الموضوع سيتم مناقشته
وقبل قليل اكتب انه تم مناقشه هذا الموضوع
بعيدا في المؤتمر الصحفي عند لقائه بارئيس
السيسي قال سن- نناقش ملف حقوق الانسان
وهو هي مناقشات طويله وعلى اثر هذه
المناقشه همم
الاشخاص من بينهم زياد العليمي وغيرهم من
الاشخاص الذين شملتهم النقاشات الطويله
بين مصر الغربيه على راسها
لغايه المتحده الامريكيه اوضح ان الجانب
الامريكي نعم دعيني اوضح كيف كان الامر
بالنسبه للجانب الاميركي الجانب الامريكي
لديه تقارير شبه يوميا تاتي اليه عبر
السفاره الامريكيه في القاهره وفيها
تفاصيل التفاصيل عن ما يجري بالفعل لسيامه
حول ثلاث نقاط اساسيه متعلقه بالحوار
الوطني متعلقه بقائمه العفو الرئاسي وعمل
لجنه العفو الرئاسي همم ومساله علاء عبد
الفتاح بالحاله كل هذه الامور تمت
مناقشتها ولدها عندما تقدم القاهره متى
راي في بخصوص او همم هذه الملفات تحديدا
همم اعتقد ان انها على علم او صدر جيدا
بان همم
فريق المعني لاسيما انا بقول لينكين الذي
امضى سنوات طويله عقود داخل ادارات
امريكيه داخل الحزب الديمقراطي تحديدا
معني بهذه النقطه هم على علم كامل بما
يجري همم لذا دعونا ننتظر خلال الايام
القادمه اني اتوقع ان يكون هناك همم رد
فعل مصري على اساس هذا الرد همم ساعتها
هنقول اذا كان همم تم همم همم تنفيذ ما تم
الاتفاق عليه او كانت هناك اتجاهات اخرى
تفضل
اهلا وسهلا استاذ توفيق اهلا ايضا
بالضيبات هو لا شك بانه موضوع حقوق
الانسان وموضوع علاء سيطر على هذه القمه
لكن ايضا هنالك نقاط يجب ان يشار اليها
وهو غياب الصين عن هذه القمه هذه القمه
وجهها ماكرون خلال تصريحات له انتقاد
واشار بالبنان الى امريكا والى الصين
وانهم مسؤولون بدرجه كبرى عن ما يحدث
حاليا من تغير مناخ كبير وان كان الرئيس
الامريكي بيدن اشار اليوم وتباهى بانه
اعاد امريكا الى اتفاق الى اتفاق باريس و
بانه ايضا يضخم 150 مليار للدول الافريقيه
من اجل التلائهم مع التغيرات المناخيه
الحاليه لكن ليس هنالك سقف كبير من هذه
القمه نتيجه للصراع بين الدول الكبرى وعدم
التزامها بما يتم الحديث عنه من عائدات
ماليه يجب تعويض بها الدول التي تضررت من
المناخ ومن الغازات حتى جوتير تحدث عن عن
مخاوفه من جحيم مناخي يلوح في الافق ان لم
تتدارك الدول الكبرى ما يحدث حاليا
وبالتالي هي قمه يمكن ان نقول باننا نخاف
ان توضع في سله المهملات مع بقيه القمم
التي عقدت منذ 95 وحتى يومنا الحالي
تتمنى لو ان الصين وروسيا كانت موجودهتين
في هذه القمه لكي تلعب مصر دور الوسيط بين
كل هذه الاطراف وحتى بعض الاطراف المقربه
من الرئاسه في مصر كانت همم قبيل القمه
همم تعد بمفاجاه خلال هذه القمه ربما حتى
مفاجاه قد تنهي الحرب الاوكرانيه ان همم
بوادر او بوابه
المفاوضات بين الجانب الروسي قد تفتح من
خلال هذه القمه كان يعول الكثير على ان
تلعب مصر خلال هذه القمه دور المتبقي
لديها والذي ايضا اشارت اليه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي انها ستكون هي
الوسيط امام الدول الاقل نموا ولاسيا
الدول الافريقيه التي كانت لديها الكثير
من المطالب منذ اللحظه الاولى لانطلاق هذه
القمه وانا كنت هناك انا الكل يتحدث عن
ضروره الاعتراف بالمسؤوليه التي لا تقدم
المساعدات على شكل القرود لابد ان تتم على
شكل هي او تعويضات اا غير لا تسترد وانت
ان يكون ذلك بمثابه الاعتراف بالخطا الذي
يرتكب على مدى عقود وقرون من قبل الدول
الصناعيه الكبرى حتى هذه اللحظه هذه
النقطه لم تحسم بعد حتى وان كان هناك
التزامات ولكن بعض حتى المفوضين يقولون هي
مساله كسب الوقت قمه التنفيذ هي فقد
التركيز على كلمه التنفيذ لكسب المزيد من
الوقت حتى عام 2000
30 ولا نعلم اذا ذلك الحين هل بالفعل سيتم
الالتزام بهذه التعاهدات ام لا في ظل هذه
المتغيرات الدوليه وكل همم الصعوبات
الاقتصاديه التي يمر بها العالم وهذه
الدول التي لديها ايضا اولويات لكن
الضمانه الوحيده من قبل كثيرين هي اا ان
الدول الكبرى عانت هي الاخرى خلال سنوات
الاخيره من الجفاف وجدت ان مزارعيها ايضا
يعانون لذلك هم ايضا مثل ما حدث عند رائحه
قران هناك همم قارن حالتين انا وحينها همم
احتشدت الدول الكبرى وقامت بتصنيع اللقاح
في فتره همم قصيره هنا ايضا ربما يتم
تسريع التنفيذ تنفيذ كل ما تم الاتفاق
عليه خلال القمم الماضيه
انعدام الثقه بين الدول الغنيه والدول
الفقيره خاصه فيما يتعلق بتسديد التعويضات
الان نتحدث عن ملايين في حين انا المنتظر
هي مليارات الدولارات وليس ملايين دولارات
من الاحتباس الحراري اي الدول دول جنوب
ااا مخي راح لتعويضات الاستعمار القديم
يعني
ههه
اوضعها مختلف تماما افريقيا انظر الى
كيفيه نظر الدول الكبرى الى القاره
الافريقيه تحديدا مثلا
او اي دول اخرى همم تعرضت
لمواقف اقتصاديه او جفاف واعراض مناخيه
يعني يصعب همم لهذه الدول ان اا تتلفاها
او تحلها انظر الى ما يدور في جعبه هذه
الدول الكبرى لتعرف تحديدا ما الذي يمكن
ان يقدم الى هذه الدول انا اتكلم هنا عن
افريقيا افريقيا هي اكثر الدول احنا راينا
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين كيف همم حاله
الجفاف في كينيا مثلا دي بلد الرئيس اسره
الرئيس التي ينحدر منها الرئيس الامريكي
اوباما همم انظر الى غرب افريقيا التي
تعاني الان من صدامات تعاني من همم همم
جمعات يطلق عليها لانها جمعات ارهابيه
بينما تتواجد القوات الامريكيه افريكان في
الغرب الامريكي وتغادر او غادرت بالفعل
القوات الفرنسيه من هناك
واتت بعد قوات روسيه الى هناك هذا المشهد
كله كيف كيف يتم صرف تعويضات في اطار وجود
عامل سياسي بيفرض نفسه لا سيما وان
افريقيا تعني للبعض خاصه لوشنطن همم
كاحتياطي من الثروه استراتيجي للمستقبل
همم عندما نتحدث عن تعويضات تصرف لهذه
الدول اعتقد ان سيدخل هذا العام فيها وان
التعويضات قد تصرف همم بشكل همم ساخي الى
الدول التي تؤدي تعاونا ايه همم وفي اطار
محاوله امريكيه لطرد الصين وروسيا من
التواجد في القاره الافريقيه اما على
مختلف دول العالم فانا همم يعني عندي
قناعه بان مستوى التعاطي او التعاون او
الاستفاده التي ان تحققها الدول العالم
الغربي او الدول السخيه او الدول التي
تعطي المال لتعويض هذه الدول سا همم يكون
همم يعني متحكم به بشكل اكبر هو كميه
الاستفاده او الخطط الاستراتيجيه وخطط
المصالح التي تعني الدول المانيا
يتحدث بان الولايات المتحده في بوعودها
لعام 2030 يعني هذا همم
امر طوباوي
هذا كلام اكثر منه على ارض الواقع استاذ
توفيق حاليا العالم يشهد نوع من الحجه
ونوع من النزوح الى الحرب والى المواقف
المتصلبه وبالتالي اعتقد ان هذه التصريحات
فقط هي مجرده ذرى للرماد في العيون امام
الراي العام والاداره الامريكيه تعي حاليا
ما تواجهه من مشاكل خصوصا الاستقطاب مع
روسيا ومع الصين التي غابت عن هذه القمه
وتتجه الى القمه حاليا الى ان تكون
بروتوكليه وتحمل كثير من الوعود لكن صفر
على ارض الواقع فقط تمويلات ساقيه ستخرج
من امريكا لبعض الدول الافريقيه ولكن على
صعيد الطاقه وعلى صعيد التصنيع والمعدات
العسكريه لن يكون هنالك اي سياسه سواء
الوعود لان العالم حاليا يشهد هذه الموجات
التصعيديه بين الدول الكبرى للاسف الشديد
قمه للتشبيك للعلاقات وكذلك لعقد الصفقات
وال اتفاقيات لانه على هامش القمه عقدت
الكثير من الصفقات الاستثماريه كنت بدايه
القمه ههه وعدته حتى يعني حاولت تشبيك
العلاقات لكن لم اعقد اي صفقه للاسف كنت
فاشله جدا في الصفقات
لكن كنت اشاهد كيف انا المليارات طاقه
صفقات
هذه الطاقه الجديده والمتجدده وصفقات في
مجال الهيدروجين الاخضر والازرق وغيرها من
الاشياء اذا هناك دول عده همم لديها خطط
طموحه للاستثمار في هذه الدول التي تريد
ان تتحول ليس لديها القدره الماديه لا
سيما في الدول الافريقيه هناك همم ارض
خصبه جدا للاستثمارات الجديده بنسبه لدول
المتقدمه ستستفيد للمره الثانيه هذه الدول
استفادت صناعيه من الطاقه الاحفوريه اليوم
ستستفيد عبر نقل التكنولوجيا والاستثمار
فيها في هذه الدول وهذا ما يحدث بالفعل
ربما من الان حتى عام 2030 ليست كل الدول
ستستفيد ولكن اللعبه السياسيه كما ذكرت
السيده حنان هي التي تكون لها الكلمه
الفيصل لان همم يعني مثلا همم ان من
سيستفيده هذا ما انتقدته الكثير من
المنظمات المجتمع المدني على هامش القمه
ان الملف السياسي ولاسيما الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا او الحرب الفعليه بين موسكو
واشنطن هي من ستحسم الامور من سيستفيد من
المساعدات ومن القروض المقدمه في مجال
الطاقه البديله والجديده والتحول البيئي
ايضا
هذه المحثه
التوفيق تعليق سريع المستفيد الوحيد هو
مصر ربما يكون هنالك بلوره للعلاقات ما
بين مصر حاليا خصوصا في ظل الانتقالات
حقوق الانسان وبعض الجزاء بين الاداره
الديمقراطيه والرئيس السيسي اخر زياره
كانت زياره اوباما الشهيره لكن حاليا ربما
يكون هناك نوع من الصفا بين الاداره
الامريكيه والرئيس السيسي خصوصا الحديثه
بين الاطراف الفلسطينيه مصر هي شريقه قوي
في الحرب على الارهاب هو ذكره واوضح على
الصعيد حقوق الانسان على سعيد حقوق
الانسان لا يمكن ان يركز فقط على حقوق
الانسان وينسى هذا الدور الذي تلعبه مصر
اقليميه لذلك هناك ضغط هناك
ملف حقوق الانسان والدفاع عن الديمقراطيه
وباذن يريد ان يسجل موقفا
في داخل الامريكي ولكن ما يجري في الخارج
لعبه مصالح وترتيبات السياسيه اخرى مختلفه
تماما يستخدم فيها ملف حقوق الانسان
احيانا كبره قد ضغط من الجانب الامريكي
بقى همم
نعم اتفضل
اعتقد ذلك
مصري
ترتقي عرش افريقيا ان ارادت ولكن عليها ان
تفعل جهد كبير جدا لان الولايات المتحده
في معركتها القادمه والغير تقليديه مع
الصين للاحتواء والتي يقف بوتن المطلوب هو
اختفاء بوتن فقط وليس الدخول في حرب مع
روسيا يقف امام تلك الطموحات الامريكيه
واشنطن ستكون معنيه بان يستمر مصالحها في
القاره الافريقيه وفي محيط الشرق الاوسط
الكبير بواسطه بعض الحلفاء او الاصدقاء في
حاله هدوء نسبي وانسيابيه في التعاطي مع
جدوله المصالح الموجوده الامريكا
مباشره
وفي داخل البيت الابيض حول مثلا همم فتح
همم بوابه المفاوضات مع الرو هناك ميل لدى
الولايات المتحده عندما ذكر عبد الفتاح
السيسي في افتتاح قمه شرم الشيخا ولابد من
انهاء الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ايده جو
بيضا عندما وصل اليوم انه لابد من انهاء
هذه الحرب والمؤشرات كانت كثيره خلال همم
الساعات الماضيه على امكانيه ان يكون هناك
مفاوضات
اعتقد ان كلام بيض بياتي في سياق احتماليه
ان يكون هناك بعض اللقاءات على هامش قمه
ال 20 التي سيذهب اليها بيضا وان كان
سيتوقف في كمبودي اولا فهو غادر بالفعل
ولكن هنا نحن نتحدث عن همم مصر اذا همم
سمحت لي»
والملفات الامريكيه التي تريد واشنطن ان
يتم تعاطي بها وامكانيه ان تكون مصر بهذا
الدور ولكن لان حتى تقوم مصر بهذا الدور
ينبغي ان ترى واشنطن حسب فهمي من الجانب
الامريكي على الاقل بعد ال- ال- الحراك
الجدي وليس فقط همم مكتوب او ما يقال همم
بشكل همم دون تفاصيل الى الجانب الامريكيه
رسميا بخصوص ملفات عده ملف ليبيا همم همم
تعلمون ان ليبيا مهمه جدا لواشنطن التي
ترغب ان تعود بعد من يعني هي غابت من
الحرب العالميه الثانيه عن طرابلس الغرب
كقاعده لقوات افريكانب همم كم التي ستقوم
بدور فاعل اساسي لحمايه وحراسه المصالح
الامريكيه في افريقيا تريد من مصر ان اا
تتعاطى بشكل اا سلس مع بعض قضايا الاخرى
سواء داخليا على مستوى حقوق الانسان
على سبيل المثال مصر تريد همم لا تطلق
الولايات المتحده يد الاتراك مثلا في
ليبيا واشنطن همم واشنطن كانت يهمها على
تطلق يد الروس وقوات همم
فاجن في ليبيا قبل بالضبط قبل همم تركيا
يعني تبقى تركيا في الاساس يعني اسمحي لي
هي حليف للولايات المتحده وفيها قواعد
امريكيه همم وان كان جانب منها هي اساسا
تابعه للناس همم
بالنسبه لتركيا
واشنطن اوضحت لجانب المصري اكثر من مره
بان ما يتم سواء عبر مصر او عبر دول
الخليجيه بالنسبه للتعاطي من خلال حفتر
امر لم يعد لا غير مرغوب فيه على الاساس
واعتقد ان هناك تفهمات حول يعني تحول
تدريجي او سير تدريجي ربما نرى حفتر يختفي
عن الصحه الليبيه
واذا راينا هذا المشهد امامنا فالامي انا
واشنطن همم
استاذ توفيق بسرعه بسرعه
حاليا
الجديده بعد سته اشهر في افريقيا يتحدث عن
استراتيجيه عسكريه يقول لن نتخلى عن
افريقيا وفي نفس الوقت هناك انسحاب للقوات
الفرنسيه من اكثر بلد
عم يعتمد اا
عن
نفود الفتبقي ال- ال- المرحله الاخيره
التي شهدت فيها فرنسا اعتراضا كبيرا من
قبل شعوب عده
وفي مالي لا سيما على وجه الخصوص ودول
الاخرى تبعت مالك ذلك ولكن لن ينتهي هذا
الوجود ولا هذه العلاقه همم بين القاره
السمراء وفرنسا من المستحيل ذلك ولكن هي
اعاده موضوع
ورسم استراتيجيه بشكل مختلف اا انهاء ما
يثير غضب الناس في قضيه مالي وجود القوات
الفرنسيه وقوه فرخان هذا اثر غضب الكثيرين
لاسيما انه معتبرها ان فاشلت في الحرب على
الارهاب ولكن اليوم لابد من همم عندما
تقوم فرنسا بتدريب الجيوش الوطنيه في
الدول الافريقيه وان توفر لهم نقاط دعم
عسكريه موجوده في دول ستتفاوض معها ربما
تشاد ربما من جمال همم تكون تلك النقاط
وغيرها من النقاط الاخ لا يعني ان نفوذ
فرنسا انتهى هي تحاول ان ترسم استراتيجيه
جديده مرضيه للشباب تحديدا هذا الجيل الذي
او هذه الفئه التي تمثل غالبيه الشعوب في
افريقيا ستعود اليهم فرنسا من بوابه اخرى
لكن الوجود العسكري لن ينتهي تماما
امريكا هي التي ترسم خط السير للجميع يعني
بدات هي بالانسحاب من اكثر من مكان في
يعني الدول الاخرى تسير دائما على خطى وشد
مثل ما كان في البدايه الموضه كانت دائما
تاتي من امريكا كل شيء ياتي من امريكا
خلاص نحن وراء ما ياتي من امريكا حتى في
المجال العسكري
نعم اكيد
تشير الى تراجع الى تراجع كبير
تراجع كبير لفرنسا في افريقيا بشكل كبير
وهزيمه امام الروس الذين بداوا يتصدارون
المشهد يبدو انه الاداره الفرنسيه حاليا
مع ماكرون لم تتبع خطه امنيه قويه جدا في
مواجهه زحف العناصر الارهابيه ما كلف
العديد من الخسائر ما كلف التذمر شعب كبير
داخل الدول الافريقيه من هذا الضعف
الفرنسي اضافه الى ايضا تراجع الاداره
الامريكيه عن التمويل لقوات برخان حيث كان
هنالك دعم امريكي ساخني بارخان وكل هذا
يؤكد انه فرنسا حاليا تكاد تخرج من اللعبه
في افريقيا وهنالك سيطره واضحه للروس
المظاهرات التي شاهدناها فيتشاد في
بوركينا فاسو وفي ماريو خطر الجماعات الذي
بدا يتسرب الى بنين وبعض الدول الاخرى
وهنالك نوع من الصقر واضح جدا همم على
فالنسيا ماكرو وهو يحاول حاليا ان يقدم
استراتيجيه جديده يحاول من خلالها ادخال
امريكا
وتقديم نوع من التهديئه لهذه الدول لكن
خلاص روسيا ربحت اللعبه في افريقيا
ولو ان الان
تربح روسيا اللعبه في افريقيا بقوه معروف
ان هي ميليش يعني همم اذا تكلمنا عن غرب
افريقيا تحديدا سنرى بان همم فرنسا التي
همم انهت عمليه برخان بعد هي بدايتها عام
2014 بعد سنه واحده من عمليه سرفال اللي
همم استمرت لمده سنه وتتذكرون كيف كانت
هناك همم محدثات امريكيه فرنسيه وكانت
فرنسا لا تريد الخروج بهذا الشكل لا صيام
تاريخيه هي لها همم في افريقيا او تعتقد
ان لها كثير في افريقيا ولكن اذا راينا
المشهد الحالي اذا راينا عدد العمليات
الارهابيه التي تضاعف الى 88 عمليه تقريبا
في هذا العام 2022 بينما كان العدد اقل من
ذلك بكثير اعتقد 20 او 22 في عام 17 مثلا
واذا راينا في نفس الوقت كيف ان اا اا اا
فرنسا سحبت بالفعل قوتها من اغسطس هي
تتحدث الان عن سحب الحالي لا لا العمليه
بركان وصاحب القوات اا كان في هذه الفتره
من اغسطس الماضي منذ عده اشهر راينا كيف
ان الولايات المتحده الان اصبحت في مواجهه
روسيا ومن غير الدقيق ان نقول بان روسيا
قد ربحت المعركه لان هناك همم الصين التي
اا نجحت الولايات المتحده خلال السبع
سنوات الاخيره في همم ظهرها عن طريق
التعاون الامريكي المباشر مع الدول
الافريقيه امر ثاني مهم جدا ان الانقلابات
التي حدثت مؤخرا ااه سياما في غرب افريقيا
اتت بحكومات ضد همم معروف انهم ضد الوجود
الفرنسي في تلك المنطقه كل هذه الامور
تدعونا الى القول بان الولايات المتحده
المتميكزه والتي نقلت همم قوات افريكانو
همم وموجوده حاليا في الغرب الافريقي ليس
امامها سوى التعاطي مع فاجنر والاستمرار
في عمل ارضيه همم مباشره سواء عبر مساعدات
عبر المصالح المتبادله عبر الحوار واستمال
رؤساء دول الاقوى تجارب الولايات المتحده
بخير اذا كانت تجربه في افغانستان وغيرها
من المناطق لم تثبت نجاح القوات الامريكيه
عزيزتي ربما تدومي الصومال مثلا تجربه
الولايات المتحده والقوات الامريكيه
التدخل سياسي والحصول على مصالح بالسياسه
وبالمساعدات
وبالعلم ايضا الولايات المتحده ولا يخفى
على احد هذا تمتلك اا تكنولوجيا اليه
تطوير الرفاينريس بتاعه البترول في العالم
متطوره
الصين تمتلك تقنيات لكن ليست تقنيات هندسه
عمل الرفاينرز او المصافي الخاصه بالبترول
لذا عندما الان هذه مثال جنوب افريقيا
صممت شركه امريكيه لها
مفاعصه بترول اربع احجام اكبر مصفه بترول
في العالم الى الان رغم انها ذهبت الى
الصين وتفاوضت معهم لم تتمكن جنوب افريقيا
من تنفيذ هذا المشروع نعم ولكن المشكله
دائما في في القاره الافريقيه هي الشروط
الامريكيه التي
موجوده موجوده
الى اخمص قدميها بالملفات الداخليه وتغيب
عن امداد فرنسا والتعاون معها لذلك قل
لصدام للقوات الفرنسيه باركان وغيرها وعلى
ارض الواقع للاسف هنالك حكومات وهنالك
ميزان شعبي ضد فرنسا يستحضر الام
الاستعمار الماضي يستحضر سرقه ثروات
الافريقيه يستحضر كل هذه الالام ويتجه الى
روسيا التي
تضع بوصلتها عبر فاجنر عموما حتى الان
فاجنر اثبتت انها بديل لا باس به من خلال
الحد من بعض العمليات الارهابيه التي تحدث
ويبدو انه مكروه حاليا يريد يريد مد اليد
من امريكا وامريكا بادن لا تعطي اي اهتمام
لافريقيا او التواجد داخل
العوامل التي غيرت فعلا
الاستراتيجيا كان الفرنسيه او حتى
الامريكيه قال هذه جبهه مفتوحه ومعقده جدا
في وقت همم تجتمع فيه الدول الكبرى دول
الغربيه في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كذلك
انقلابات التي كل يوم انقلاب في افريقيا
فيدسات في بوركينا فاسو وكل هذه الاوضاع
تساهم الى حد الان انه فرنسا تخرج من
السرعه تفضل يا حنان
شكرا على مساعدتك
ههه عايزه اوضح نقطه مهمه جدا لان
الولايات المتحده على المستوى الداخلي
والمحلي قد يكون في اختلاف في اختلاف في
اساليب التعاطي مع المطالب اللي جماهيريه
مطالب المواطنين اا في تنافس ولكن عندما
يتعلق الامر بالمصالح الامريكيه الخارجيه
قد تتغير صوره التعاطي اا اا حزب هويه ال-
ال- المدير التنفيذي الجالس في البيت
الابيض ولكن في نهايه الامر المصالح
الامريكيه
الخطوط الاساسيه الموضوع واللي بتكتب في
التقرير الاستراتيجي الذي يصدر كل 10
سنوات هذه الخطوط
لا محال من الشك بان اي رئيس ان كان احمر
ام ازرق يعمل على تنفيذ هذه المخططات مع
حلقه استثنائيه واحده وهي حاله الرئيس
الاسبق ترامب فكان حاله يونيك كما يقولوا
يعني حاله فريده من نوعها نمر الى الموضوع
الثالث وهذه الانتخابات النصفيه طبعا
والكلمه لك ضيفي في واشنطن يعني كنا ننتظر
صفعه قويه جدا
لبعيدن همم كل عمليه استطلاع الراي كل
المقالات يعني هلكونا بالقصه صفعه وموجه
حمراء وموزه زرقاء وموجه لست ادري ماذا
وفي النهايه خلاص حتى موضوع مجلس الشيوخ
لم يحسم بعد وننتظر النتائج واعاده
انتخابات في اكثر من من ولايه يعني كانوا
متوقع ان هذا لان عاده عندما يتعلق الامر
بنسبه تضخم تتجاوز الثمانيه في المئه فان
الرئيس يحسن يهزم بصوره اوتوماتيكيه اذا
ما هي ما هو سحر بيضا
فعلا استاذ توفيق كونان انتظروا ماردا
احمر يسيطر على مجلس النواب وعلي الشيوخ
لكن معظم الاراء التي طرحت مؤخرا هو ان
هنالك خلاف داخل الحزب الجمهوري وتحميل
للمسؤوليه لترامب وللمرشحين الذين اختارهم
في هذا السباق والذين يوصفوا بانهم لديهم
نزعه تطرديه كان هذا الانتقاد واضح من
نائب الرئيس السابق بانس ومن عديد من
المسؤولين الجمهوريين ايضا اضافه الى ان
الديمقراطيين وبايدا نستفادوا من الغضب
النساء تجاه حق الاجهاض هذا الحق الذي ترى
نسبه امريكا بانه دستوري ولا يمكنه المساس
به لعب عليه الديمقراطيون كبيرا اضافه الى
نجاح بايدا في طرق همم والعزف على منوال
انه هنالك خطر على الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
عموما ما حدث يوحي بانه هنالك نوع من
اعاده سبب داخله الحزب الاحمر الحزب
الجمهوري وربما حظوظه والموجه الترامبيه
ستتراجع الى صالح رجل اخر 40 هو ديسانتوس
الذي يقال بانه الوجه الجديد الذي تروج له
الصحابه الامريكيه طبعا هي في خصومه دائما
مع ترامب بانه سيكون المرشح المنافس
للترامب وبالتالي كان كل هذا هو العوامل
الاساسيه في تراجع الحزب الجمهوري وان
كانت السيطره على مجلس النواب ستكون ايضا
تعطي حراره ونوع من الشد والجذب داخل
الحياه السياسيه الامريكيه ما قبل عامين
من نهايته حكم
بالتالي ليست ليس ساحر
دونالد ترامب وهذا الانشقاق الذي احدثه
داخل الحزب الجمهوري هو الذي تسبب في ذلك
وايضا الصحافه كما ذكر سيد ده يعقوب لان
ااا
الاله الاعلاميه بمعظمها وبمجملها هي اله
لا تؤيد دونالد ترامب ولا تؤيد الترامب
بيسما او الترامبيين وبالتالي او الفكره
ترامبي
ههه
طبعا ههه
اذا سمحتوا لي اعتقد بان الصفحه الكبرى
التي همم يعني اطلقت من طلقها هو ترامب في
حد ذاته كما تعلمون الفوز الصاحق الاحرزه
الديمقراط يعني ولايه بنسلفانيا في مقابل
همم همم
فشل همم مرشح ترامب الدكتور محمد
جراح متقاعد همم في هذه الولايه كانت له
مغزى ايضا بالنسبه للصحافه والاعلام راينا
كيف تخلت اعلام ترامب الاعلام المحسوب عن
ترامب عنه في ولايه فلوري ده هو رايناهم
كيف صوتوا لصالح المرشح همم اللي هو اصلا
مرشح كي يخوض انتخابات الحزب الجمهوري همم
في الانتخابات المقبله في نهايه الامر
اعتقد بان الحزب الديمقراطي همم لم ينجح
صحيح ولكنه احرز تقدما امام الحزب
الجمهوري ولم يتمكن همم الحزب الجمهوري من
فرد سيطرته على كلا المجلسين امنا اعاده
همم فرز او انتخابات اخرى همم في ربما في
ديسمبر المقبل على مقعد او اثنين ولكن في
نهايه الامر صحيح
انا نجاح امام نجاح ديمقراطي في الحد من
تحويل وهو تحويل تقليدي على فكره يعني ده
عاده ان الحزب الديمقراطي المفروض انه
يعني يخسر بشكل اكبر
الى حزب يؤدي دوره
في بعض الملفات مريحه اذا ااه بسبب هذه
النتائج في مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ هنا
تكواندو المشكله
هل خدم هل خدم ترامب
الجمهوريين عندما لما الاحتمال الاعلان عن
ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه وعندما نرى
عمليه استطلاع الراي
ان الامريكيين يفضلون ديسانتس على ترامب
يعني هذه ضربه التراب لان هناك الان شرح
داخل الحسبه
هو الان اصبح المشكل
صحيح استاذ توفيق للاسف الشديد يبدو ويبقى
كما يقول انصار ترامب من انه هنالك انحصار
للماده الترامبي وظهور لدي سانتوس كمرشح
ربما يكون توافق داخل الحزب الجمهوري هو
ترامب حاول خلال عده خرجات ان ينتقد
ديسانتوس ويشير الى انه الاصوات التي حصل
عليها في الانتخابات 2020 تضاهي ما حصل
عليه سانتوس حاليا لكن يبدو انه البيت
الاحمر حاليا بدا بمحاوله جديده للتجديد
والخروج من النزعه ترامبيه التي سيطرت
عليه والتي طردت عده نواب مثل تشيني
وغيرهم وبدا حتى بينس يتحدث عن عهد جديد
غير عهد ترامب ربما نشهد خلال الايام
القادمه ما بعد اعلان ترامب عن الترشحه
معارضه كبيره داخل الحزب الجمهوري لهذا
الترشح وان كانت ترامب يعتمد على شعبيته
التي يقول بان هذا ثابته ولا تتزعزع
لم يعترف بالنتائج حتى عندما كان رئيسا
فما بالك هل بالطبع سيخضع
لاراده الحزب الجمهوري وهو غير رئيس ومن
سيتمكن من ازاحه ترامب حتى عن الحزب
الجمهوري هذا هو الاشكال الان
هو اشكال كبير جدا ربما استطلاعات الراي
وحتى الشارع يشير الى ديسانتوس لكن ترامب
رقم صعب ولديه قاعده جماهيريه كبيره ولديه
المال ولديه من الصحاريا يخاطب منها
الجماهير ولديه تويتر حاليا ماسك يتجه
الاتجاه جمهوري ربما كل هذه العوامل تساهم
في اعاده ترامب ان يكون طائره
ان يتم محاكم ذكريات اقتحام الكابته وهذه
الفوضى والمجتمع الامريكي غير معتاد ولا
ولا يحب هذه المناظر داخل المجتمع
الامريكي
بالانتخابات يعني يذهب مع المترشحين ويروج
لهم يروج لهم
وصلته الرساله عده مرات لكنه تجاهلها
ترامب رساله كانت اذا جرا على الترشح او
حلم بالترشح ولوك مستقل فان ملفات اا
ايصاله الى السجن متاحه وكثيره
قهوه السجن
جمهوري بيحاول ان يتخلص من ورق الترامب
التي كانت سببا في خسارته على مستوى
القاعده كما يقولون بينما بالتخلص هو يرفض
الاعتراف
الحياه السياسيه مثلا عند اصبحت بالنسبه
لدونالد ترامب ان يعود مجددا للوجه
السياسيه
اعتقد انه تجاوز عديد
المساءلات القانونيه وشاهدناه يسرح ويمرح
ويتجول مع المترشحين امثال اوز وغيرهم من
الذين دعمهم وكان موجودا وطاغيا على
المشهد السياسي اعتقد انه محاكمته اصبحت
في خبر كان لكن حاليا العرقل الاساسيه هي
هل سيترشح وهل يستطيع ان يهزم المحافظين
داخل الحزب الجمهوري كما هزم كل التوقعات
واستطاع ان يكون المرشح الاوفر والابرز
لحزب الجمهوري 2016
صفا ليست مساله
تصرفاسه ما مساله تطرف ترامب ترامب غمر
خلال وجوده في البيت الابيض
وقام بفعل ضد الدستور الامريكي عندما رفع
البيض بالامام البيت الابيض وساعتها تم
اتخاذ القرار امريكا همم هناك همم حكماء
موجودين ولهم كلمه ترامب على ما اعتقد
لديه ملفات كبيره يمكن ان تفتح في اي وقت
ولا دي همم وهناك وهمم مخلفات همم زعقه قد
تؤدي به اذاء الى السجن اذا تمسك بمساله
الترشح وهذا يعني دي معلومات معروفه
سطور
ما تقول حلال بدري اعتقد ان قصده هو ان
كسب الديمقراطيين ليه مجلس الشيوخ هو الذي
يخول ايضا بان يعين القضاه وبالتالي هذا
ربما يساعد اعتقد هذا ما فهمته هذه
الرساله التي تريد ان تبلغها لنا حنان من
القاهره شكر في الختام للزميل المنطقه
الدهنيه سعد صبري وصحفيه في مونت كارلو
طبعا حنان البدري من القاهره وكاتبه صحفيه
والداي يعقوب من واشنطن وهو كاتب و صحفي
برامجكم بالعربيه والفرنسيه
والانجليزيه والاسبانيه متواصله على فرانس
فالكادر
[موسيقى]